Raymond is with us in Los Angeles he's a
truck driver he's got thirty nine
thousand dollars in back child support
he's got student loans he's got other
debts totalling up over a hundred
thousand he makes seventy thousand a
year what do we do now and that was how
far we got in the discussion does that
sound like a fair summary so far Raymond
yes I make about 60 right now and also
I'm expecting a possible promotion next
month which would take you to what kind
of an income about 90 actually Oh
wonderful okay that's me helped me going
from that team driver to a trainer right
now you have back child support are you
current on your child support not
counting the back child support as of
January I've been able to start being
current okay so the first step to
getting out of debt is to stop borrowing
more in the case of child support to
stop going further in the hole plus it's
very important that you take care of
your children agreed yeah okay so that's
first you eat you keep lights on and you
have food transportation shelter basic
necessities of life is all and you pay
your child support yes and by the way
just mentioning that I'm also uh
actually I'm homeless and I have no car
I live out of my truck I Drive 28 days a
month to my kids two days a month okay
so you are but you're not homeless in
the traditional sense you're just saying
I'm choosing to live in my truck right
now
to not have the overhead and you're
driving over the road right yes and I'm
in a rush to fix that
yeah okay well that's where you would be
even if you have an apartment right yeah
okay so you're just not wasting the
money on the apartment since you're
staying in the truck all the time and
that's good right now because you got a
mess on your hands and if you get a
promotion what happens is it's the same
thing yes okay all right good
okay so the good news is we don't have a
lot of shelter expense a lot of lights
and water and that kind of thing but
taking care of your children for any of
us whether you're in the home or whether
you're not is way at the top of the list
of priorities so we're going to stay
current from this point forward on child
support for the rest of your life until
these children are
agreed yes okay then from there we're
going to list your debts smallest to
largest and you said you had 39,000
child support and you what else that
makes up the over 150,000 in student
loans and 28,600 I broke it down as a
basically I have two of them they're
like tickets if I with them as consumers
to or medical and through your kind of
loans from family and friends got to pay
back and two of them already paid off
okay I'm sorry that's the 28,000 26 yes
okay break the 28 six down for me okay I
have two tickets I need to pay they're
not any kind of risk of sustaining my
license or anything like that one is
about 580 the other is about 93 okay
clear those up today you're the money in
the checking account today that today no
I get paid every week though I'll take
care of those uh Friday okay good okay
then what else have you got
I got five consumer debts like Verizon
Sprint stuff like that I come out to
here's what I want you to do let's try
again let's just start from the scratch
I want you when you get off the phone to
list your debts all of them broken down
not by category by individual debt small
laughs we have actually happened that I
used to think all gun debt it got my
teeth and I actually have been down
there okay so we're gonna we're going to
list them smallest to largest in great
detail anything that's under $1,000
you're gonna clean up very very quickly
you got four or five of those those are
just little mosquitoes we're just gonna
swat them like we did those tickets a
minute ago okay so you're gonna get all
that cleaned up then I want you to put
the child's back child support at the
top of your list I want you to get that
monkey off your back as fast as you can
just just start piling big big checks on
that
to the Children's Services or whoever
you're paying the child support to if
you're in California however that's
going and work out a plan and I want you
to start paying thousands and thousands
and thousands of dollars a month towards
that back child support like all your
money's going towards that and pay
minimum payments on everything else and
then when you get that done then take
the list of what's left smallest to
largest and work it off in that order
but the back child support is a moral
obligation as well as a legal obligation
and as a dad you want that off your back
you want that behind you and then that
will move you forward on everything else
so now I've got the little ones get
those mosquitoes out of the way the the
things that are thousand dollars or less
right quickly take a month or two and do
that and then I want you to pay
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars as much as you can you ought to
be able to pay soon as the promotion
comes through you'll pay like four grand
a month in like ten months the back
child support to be done and or more if
you can and and you just get you just
get this thing you're you know you're
just not spending any money all you're
doing is paying on debt and living in
the truck and you're making 90 grand and
you can plow through one hundred and
some thousand and a couple years doing
that and you'll be debt-free in two
years easy easy
with what you're doing probably faster
than that and that will be a huge relief
and then you get your fresh start you
know you get the mistakes of your life
in your rearview mirror and you get to
start again but it's going to take you
18 to 24 months of no life living in the
truck all the money's going at the debts
and you can do this